[Music]  hey  dad go get your tools i'll meet you in  the truck  i'm looking for directions to shogum  hills i never heard that  what are you expecting to find here even  with a great fire people don't just  disappear  something else happened  what are you doing here we shouldn't be  here  want them gone  why do you need private security for a  scientific expedition willing to keep  you safe  safe from what hey hold on one second  hearing something down there how's that  what turn it up listen to this  what is that this doesn't feel right  terry did you hear that what was that  thing  how long's this been open  we do security and protection work what  is it you protect  you they took my son  and i've been fighting him ever since  listen what is that  i hear  no something what you do don't let him  grab you  get me out of here  [Music]  you